the Joe Rogan experience a lot of people
have their own idea about what to do and
what not to do but I I learned this from
a guy named Chad Ward his uh label on
Instagram is whiskey bent BBQ oh yeah
and he's a world champion pitmaster and
this [ __ ] guy can cook his ass oh my
god he's cooked for us a few times in in
hunting camps and his food is insane
he's so good
and that's his philosophy is the reverse
sear meth is where I learned it from I
learn it from him a lot of times people
will cook it they're seared on the
outside and then they try to finish it
off and you can do that that way but
it's not as good it's better to bring it
up to temperature slowly inside like a
pellet grill another good method is
Susie do you ever sous-vide things I I
haven't yet I've had it from restaurants
before though yeah I was talking to
someone they said a lot of restaurants
now do that just so they can kind of
make their all their stuff more uniform
so you go and you get exactly what you
did the last time
yeah they don't no one [ __ ] up because
if you go you know you can go to
restaurant order medium-rare and it
comes out well right yeah I've had that
happen right but the sous-vide method is
fantastic too because say if you have a
steak and you want that steak to be a
hundred and thirty-five degrees you
basically put the the the setting at 135
degrees you can put it in there for four
hours mm-hmm so when you get it it's
just all the tendons and ligaments and
all that stuff is just broken down all
the fash is broken down and it's just so
tender but it feels weird because you're
boiling in a [ __ ] plastic bag that
seems so wrong it's like you're not I
mean I know it's a different kind of
plastic but you're not even supposed to
drink water if you're last again if your
plastic bottles been sitting in a hot
car it's like how the [ __ ] can you
apparently you can that's not an issue
at all you know to cook in it but it
makes me feel weird
eventually will here in five years that
that's gonna give us cancers I don't
know man I don't think so what is the
reason why they can okay here we're
going down a rabbit hole oh let's try
let's go down the Suvi rabbit hole why
is it okay to Suvi your food and why
doesn't it leak what is it BC peas is
that what they're worried about
EPA's bcc8 BP but just a bunch of B and
a bunch of other letters which is
supposed to be what you get
there's my losin some NASA scientists
have figured it out all right maybe not
maybe the same guy who said smoking is
fine you know doctors prefer camel
remember those ads yeah and you know I
don't think we're dealing with that but
it just feels weird but it for as far as
flavor it's a phenomenal way to cook a
particularly wild game it's really good
for because again you don't overcook it
like if you wanna cook an elk steak to
130 degrees and then blowtorch the
outside that's what a lot of people do
mm-hmm
you know that's how you finish on a su V
you basically use a [ __ ] blowtorch
uh-huh oh so I have this I guess it's
like the Elon Musk flamethrower in the
background I literally could use that
yeah because it's basically the same
thing it's just a [ __ ] torch and you
torch the outside of it to get a nice
you know caramelized crust and then the
inside you know it's perfect for thunder
yeah what does it say Jamie you don't
like it does it say it's gonna kill you
the first one just says like there's
after consider amount of research that's
been done we believe the answer is it's
safe and it's like they believe it is
left a little window well I feel like if
you don't cook in it everyday like when
the director of The Cove was in here I
always [ __ ] have a hard time saying
is less Soho yes
so hey Louie Psihoyos was in here he was
explaining how he was eating a lot of
fish before he became a vegan he he was
eating a ton of fish and his mercury
levels really shot up because a lot of
fish that's like a lot of [ __ ]
mercury and if you eat fish for morning
noon and night every day day after day
after day you can develop high mercury
mercury levels
[Applause]